I actually appreciate you asking that
question because it's one that uh that
we've had the clarify several times and
I understand why the American public has
been confused over time as dr. Redfield
mentioned initially we said based on CDC
World Health Organization and most other
major public health organizations that
the public needed to know that these
masks were not effective were shown to
be effective in preventing you if you
were a mask from catching coronavirus
another important thing to remember the
context of those statements was a run on
medical mask on n95 mask that our health
care workers were at risk what's changed
what's changed is we found out that
unlike past viruses that are spread
through the respiratory route a
significant proportion of coronavirus
cases can be traced back to asymptomatic
spread so the taskforce deliberated this
we've always told you that we will look
at the facts and we will give people
recommendations based on the best
available evidence at the time and once
we saw that a symptomatic spread we said
well mass still aren't effective and
from our from our point of view at
preventing you from catching corona
virus in a significant way but we've
always told people that they should wear
masks if they know they have symptoms to
prevent them from spreading to other
people well now that we know about 25 to
50 percent of people are spreading a
symptomatically we suggest that people
wear cloth facial coverings to prevent
asymptomatic spread you wear your mask
to protect me I wear my mask and dr.
Redfield mentioned it I've got my mask
believe I have mine on me Bob I carry
mine around with me too I wear my mask
to protect you we're six feet away which
is why I'm not wearing my mask to
protect you now and we also all have
been tested so that's why I'm not
wearing mine now
but I'll put mine on if you want me to
sir but but again important to know that
if you're going to wear a mask it's not
a substitute for social distancing still
social distancing is the number one
thing you can do number two it's
important to know that you should
practice good hand hygiene and not touch
your face because you still could touch
a surface and bring disease to your face
and number three this is the most
important while if it's just as
important please save the medical mask
the n95 for the health care workers
because the cloth facial coverings are
effective as far as we know right now
based on the best available evidence at
preventing you from spreading disease to
other people so no inconsistency there
it's just the recommendation changed
because the information changed and
that's what you want from your public
health leaders in the argument means
that you do about these systemic
transmission the honest answer to you is
no we did not that was a recommendation
of the World Health Organization and the
CDC and we gave you the best information
we could at the time so I actually a
little bit ravenna because I work hard
to try to protect the American people
and we are always going to give the
American people the best information we
have available at the time and we don't
in the up we're humble enough to say
look if we don't know we're gonna change
we're gonna change yours recommend just
eyes